all right now we're gonna go to Florida
Governor Rick Scott he's joining us from
the State Emergency Operations Center in
Tallahassee governor good morning good
morning boy we're trying to get
everybody out of these evacuation zones
thank you for helping us get our message
out this thing's getting pretty close
and it's gonna have a big impact on our
state governor do you feel how ready do
you feel you are at this point we've
been we've been working to get everybody
out we have us I've called up 7,000
members of National Guard we have very
good first responders we've got very
good emergency management teams I've
talked to President Trump almost every
day FEMA's here everybody's ready but
I've got to get people out of these
evacuation zones I got to get people if
you're not on the road in the West Coast
by noon and getting to where you need to
go this storms coming and so we've got
to get people prepared you know this is
a resilient strong state we're gonna
work hard we work together well but get
out of these evacuation zones and get to
safety
yeah governor you know we focus so much
on the keys and on South Florida now we
see that path towards the west we had
the report earlier areas like Sanibel
Island and Captiva as far as getting
people out right now what is your
biggest concern biggest concerns have
people how are you listening do you
understand the risk of this storm surge
potential 12 feet of storm surge think
about that this water flows in it's 12
feet you cannot survive this you've got
to understand this is different than
something like Andrew we didn't get to
storm surge in Andrew this and this this
is going to impact both of our coasts
it's a big big big storm but this storm
surge is what really scares me governor
what's your sense of whether people are
heeding the call mean obviously we've
seen the highways overnight were packed
but do you think you get a pretty good
feeling that most people are getting out
who need to get out
well I'm sure that some people won't but
look our shelters are are getting that
we're open up more and more shelters I
think we have over 250 shelters open now
we'll continue to open up shelters I
shut down all the schools in the state
so we'd have more safe places where we
can open up shelters I've worked working
still working to make sure people get
fuel i if they're on the road I think
but people are going to shelters but I
just want to make sure everybody
understands this is an unbelievable
massive destructive storm and it's a
it's it's
it's a killer and look I love my family
I don't want to lose one member of my
family I want everybody to have that
same attitude I want everybody to say I
love my family get to safety Governor
Rick Scott I think people are heeding
the warning we appreciate you joining us
thank you thank you and you can stay
with CBS News throughout the weekend for
extensive coverage of hurricane mm oh
we're gonna have special reports
throughout today on the network and on
our streaming service CBS n tomorrow
Sunday a special edition of CBS this
morning with Charlie Nora and Gail we'll
begin at 7 o'clock Eastern followed by
Sunday morning and face the nation